barack obama releases a 768-page memoir
and that is just part one
democrats continue to lose their minds
over trump's refusal to concede the race
and politicians call for total covert
lockdowns as the virus spreads across
the country i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity
shouldn't be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first let's talk about the fact
when you are running a business there
are lots of things
you have to spend money on personnel you
have to spend money on
inventory one thing you don't want to
spend tons of money on is hr but hr
issues can
absolutely murder your business if you
got an hr issue hr liabilities they can
really kill you but hr departments can
cost you tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
this is where bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
comes in you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy and maintain
your compliance all for just 99 bucks a
month save yourself
an absolute fortune with bambi you can
change hr from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel anytime you didn't start your
business because you want to spend all
your time on hr there's a reason
nobody likes hr you need to get it
handled because if you don't it's going
to bite you directly
on your business but instead go to
bambi.com shapiro right now to schedule
your free hr audit that's b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash appear to get started
again
bambi.com shapiro to schedule that free
hr
audit okay so the election still has not
been conceded
by president trump nor probably will it
be until all of the
states have certified their election
results and be completely real about
this president trump is behind by tens
of thousands of votes
in the states that he needs most arizona
he's down by 12 to 13 000 votes in
in georgia he's down by 14 000 votes in
pennsylvania he is down by 45 to 50 000
votes
in michigan he's down 150 000 votes
right these are margins that it's going
to be very difficult in court for him to
prove
were voter fraud or voter irregularity
does this mean
that our voting system is absolutely
clean and pure as the driven snow
100 percent not okay the fact is that
the mill in balloting system
has real problems with it when you have
hundreds of thousands millions of
ballots going out to people's old
addresses
that does create the potential for
people to take those ballots fill them
out and send them in which is why tucker
carlson on his show last night for
example
literally read off the voting records of
dead people right this does happen
if you send ballots to addresses and you
don't clean
cleanse the voter rolls which is
something democrats have forcibly
opposed right democrats have filed
lawsuits
to avoid cleaning the voter rolls of
people who are dead
well that does provide the potential for
somebody to grab that particular
ballot fill it in mail it back in this
is particularly true
when in states like california have
ballot harvesting where literally people
just go around
picking up ballots from other people you
don't even mail it in in those
circumstances you have designated
people from each particular party going
out and picking
all of those ballots up don't know what
happens with them they could
theoretically fill them out right this
does
create the potential for voter fraud and
you've seen democrats in various states
around the country
trying to get rid of signature
verification so they don't even want you
to have to verify that the signature on
the ballot matches the signature
for when you've registered to vote in
the first place right
all of this creates the serious
potential for voter fraud and voter
irregularity
all of this creates the potential for
people not to trust the system
and all of those things should be
adjudicated not only should they be
adjudicated the laws should be changed
and as we have seen in certain cases the
gop has been successful
so for example the gop right now is
suing in pennsylvania
going up to the supreme court in all
likelihood about this policy
that was created out of whole cloth by
the supreme court of pennsylvania
overruling the legislature deciding that
because of kovid
ballots that arrived after the election
could still be counted even without a
postmark
right the changes of those process
absolutely undermine electoral integrity
they absolutely undermine faith in our
electoral system and all of those
questions ought to be answered and we
ought to fight those things out we
really should these are legislative
issues
these are judicial issues and these all
should be fought out
now that's not quite the same thing
about as arguing that the proof
is that all of these elections were
skewed away from trump that this the
outcome of this was the skewing of
the election away from trump that's
something trump is going to have to show
in court so for example
in michigan michigan gop lawmakers have
called for a full audit of the election
results over serious allegations of
error
and voter fraud the republican senators
in the michigan legislature called
on jocelyn benson to do so the letter
dated friday november 13th was released
on thursday signed by two republican
state senators tom barrett and lanathis
this is according to tim pearce over at
dailywire.com
the senators requested that benson delay
certifying election results over a spate
of errors and allegations of voter fraud
that have cast out
on michigan's election process the
senators wrote every citizen deserves to
have faith in the integrity
of the election process and its outcome
it is our responsibility as elected
public servants to assure the people of
michigan
of the process's integrity through
complete transparency and the faithful
investigation
of any allegations of wrongdoing fraud
or abuse unfortunately a number of
serious allegations have been made which
cannot and should not be ignored
now it's true that none of that should
be ignored that doesn't mean that the
state is going to
suddenly flip its electors or that
they're going to hold a brand new
election
some of the errors that have been made
in terms of voter fraud or voter
irregularity are in fact just that human
error some of them probably are voter
fraud or voter irregularity
but leon wolfe over at the blaze
actually went through the affidavits
that have been presented
by the trump campaign 234 pages of
affidavits regarding alleged voter
irregularities
in michigan and leon wolf again of the
blaze which is a right-wing site
he went through all of it and what he
found is that the testimony contained in
the affidavits
pertains to fewer than a thousand total
ballots although it should be noted that
numerous afghans complained they were
not able to see what was happening
because they were required to maintain
six feet of social
distance or because people were in their
way
the material in the affidavit that's
alleging an atmosphere of intimidation
and hostility toward gop poll workers
is voluminous reading between the lines
some of the frustration experienced by
poll workers and refusal tens retain
further complaints
may have been come by honestly but there
is no way to actually tell here's the
bottom line if you lose the state by 150
thousand votes it's going to be very
very difficult to challenge the results
of that particular election
that does not mean that we should not
have a legal process okay and so the
legal process
is going forward and it is important
here to distinguish fact from rumor so
for example there's been a lot of talk
about dominion voting systems because
there is one county in michigan that we
have talked about at length on the show
already
it was called altrum county in which 6
000 votes were accidentally shifted by
manual error
from the trump campaign to the biden
campaign
and then that was fixed because they
actually have verification processes and
all this stuff is double checked
that was switched his dominion has also
been used in maricopa county
maricopa county is run in arizona by the
secretary of state of arizona who's a
republican and maricopa county didn't
have any problems with the dominion
system
so in other words a problem with a
software system that was human error in
michigan does not mean that everywhere
that uses dominion system you're going
to see 6 000 votes
shift from one side to the other side in
other words you do have to prove the
voter fraud this is this is the high
legal bar and i'm explaining the legal
bar because i think people
people have to have a a realistic
appraisal
of the situation right now the legal
appraisal of the situation
is pretty obvious and lawyers right left
and center will tell you this right just
from a legal point of view
the trump team has a very rough road to
hoe here i mean it's going to be very
difficult for them to climb this
particular hill
and prove that tens of thousands of
votes in a wide variety of states
because now
it's not just pennsylvania's
pennsylvania arizona and georgia
or were done wrongly okay now again
does that mean that there is not going
to be some proof of voter fraud there is
going to be proof of voter fraud in the
media because they're garbage at this
they've decided that voter fraud simply
doesn't exist right they've said that
voter fraud and voter irregularity are
figments of your imagination poof so
five seconds ago they were telling you
that voter fraud and voter irregularity
were going to be used by the trump
campaign and voter suppression
in order to prevent jobiden from being
elected then joe biden they think was
elected
and the first thing they do is boom
cleanest election in history
nonetheless a pennsylvania judge ruled
on thursday that voters who took
advantage of an extended deadline to
provide missing proof of id
will not have their ballots counted
because the government official who gave
the extension
lacked the legal authority to do so this
is ryan sevedra writing for daily wire
according to bloomberg law commonwealth
court judge mary hannah levitt ruled
thursday that pennsylvania secretary of
state kathy buffer
lacked the authority to extend the
original november deadline by three days
originally there was a deadline that by
november 9th if you
if you had a ballot that was not
properly marked they would have an id
check
and then lukevir just decided randomly
to extend that by three days
the ruling means the battleground state
that's already been declared for joe
biden can't count ballots from voters
who submitted missing id
between november 10th and november 12th
ballots with cured id issues received
before that are not in fact
being challenged still the number of
ballots that we're talking about here is
not in the tens of thousands of ballots
it is probably in the hundreds of
ballots if it's in the thousands it's in
the very very low thousands
of ballots okay so that is where things
stand
legally speaking now will the process
play out it will play out right
as i've been saying all along the media
are in a rush to declare this thing
mainly because they know that trump
isn't going to concede this
until all of the states have actually
verified their counts and until the
electors are selected
that's typical trump trump is not going
to do that nor is trump forced to do
that there's nothing in the constitution
there's nothing in our legal process
that says that if
nbc or abc or fox news projects that an
election has been won by a person that
you then have to concede
right that is a sort of nicety that has
been typically observed
but it is not in fact something that is
legally obligated nor does it have much
of an impact on the transition process
as
no less than joe biden himself has
stated nonetheless the media have ramped
this thing up because the idea here is
that if trump doesn't concede it's just
more evidence that republicans are
authoritarians and they're terrible and
a coup is underway we'll get to the
media's hysteria over
all of this in just a second because
again that media hysteria is not about
anything real
it is about the media attempting to
defend their own actions over the past
four years
they've been in a state of constant
hysterical insanity
for four years and then if it turns out
that donald trump
did lose the election if it turns out
that he is deemed to have lost the
election
and donald trump leaves office and we
have a peaceful transition to power
it turns out all of their weird cosplay
fantasies
about how donald trump is adolf hitler
they weren't true and the media just
blew out their own credibility for no
reason other than pure political
partisanship which is of course exactly
what they've done so they have to
maintain that fiction going forward
we'll talk about that
in just one second first for those of
you wondering where i get all of this
massive morality and energy and vigor
from i know you've been wondering
i'll tell you black rifle coffee black
rifle coffee company ceo and founder
evan hafer
started the business after over 20 years
in the us army as an infantryman special
forces soldier
and cia contractor evan founded black
rifle in 2014
along with former army ranger matt best
as the combination of two passions
developing premium fresh roasted coffee
and honoring and supporting those who
serve on the front lines
black rifle has donated over 45 000
pounds of coffee or over 1 million cups
of coffee to soldiers deployed overseas
law enforcement officers wildland
firefighters on the west coast and
medical workers during the coven 19
response
in 2020 alone for every coffee purchase
you make throughout november black rifle
will send a bag of their limited edition
holiday roast to a service member
currently deployed overseas to be
delivered by christmas morning i'll tell
you what our service members they really
really appreciate it
i'll tell you i would appreciate that if
somebody would just send me black rifle
coffee because it is absolutely
delicious
it tastes great gives you the boost that
you need in the mornings and as a person
with three children who wakes him up at
all hours of the night i need
my coffee if you want to support the
cause go to blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro today to get 20 off coffee
apparel and gear as well as 20
off your first month of the coffee club
that is blackriflecoffee.com
for 20 off coffee apparel and gear as
well as 20 off your first month
of the coffee club by the way the folks
at black rifle coffee they are awesome
awesome dudes this is this is a a
company of testosterone let me tell you
blackriflecoffee.com go check them out
right now okay so
with with all of that said it's been
amusing to watch as members of the
democratic party declare
that the election is over and that if
you have questions about the election
you're very bad person
no less a personage than stacy abrams
went on tv last night and declared that
joe biden's lead in georgia was
insurmountable she's on the view
saying this now i will note that joe
biden's lead in georgia currently
is under 15 000 votes stacey abrams lost
her gubernatorial race against brian
kemp
by 50 000 votes like four times that
number
right she lost by a lot more votes than
joe biden is currently
winning georgia according to the current
accounts she says biden's lead is
insurmountable
she also maintains she's governor of
georgia are you getting the feeling
these folks are not particularly
consistent
when it comes to their claims of voter
suppression or voter fraud and that
actually all they really care about is
the result here is governor stacy abrams
of georgia
we don't know how long it's going to
take but we are absolutely certain that
this lead
is insurmountable it is absolute and joe
biden won georgia
the reality is they have the right to
follow the law and the law permits this
type of behavior
and during my election in 2018 we fought
through the courts to make sure
every vote got counted sadly they just
want to do
a recount of what we already
accomplished and i
i wish them well but we know that joe
biden is going to be
not only the president of the united
states but the first president and 30
years from the democratic party
to carry georgia wow so she it's an
insurmountable lead guys there's no way
that any recount there is no way that
any voter fraud or voter regularity
could overturn that count says governor
stacey abrams of georgia
i'm getting very very tired of hearing
from people who are fully willing i mean
literally the dnc called her the
governor of georgia in the middle of the
dnc
and now they're talking about
undermining of democracy there's this
extraordinarily self-flattering view
that democrats have of the world
that is actually dangerous to the
country really dangerous because it
basically suggests all the angels on
theirs
are on their side and all the devils are
on the other side
okay that'll become clear when we talk
about barack obama's pathetic
self-serving 768-page first volume of
his memoir my god the pentateuch okay
the five books of moses in hebrew are
not that long
god didn't have that much to say but
barack obama has plenty to say
that was his old testament can't wait
for his new testament that'll be volume
2. by the way dude's written
what would that make his fourth memoir
his fourth memoir there's no human being
important enough they require four
memoirs
not a single human requires four memoirs
okay we'll get to
barack obama in just a second but chuck
schumer
right chuck schumer the senate minority
leader a guy who five minutes ago was
talking about
getting rid of the filibuster and
members of his caucus were talking about
adding states willy-nilly to the senate
and packing the supreme court he says
that we are at risk of a coup
in the united states because donald
trump won't just say the election is
over which again
there's no obligation for him to say the
election let's be real about this donald
trump can go kicking and screaming
and as long as he does not actually
engage in law breaking
he has not violated anything legally
right there is no threat to the
constitution if donald trump
again donald trump can be whoever donald
trump wants to be he can
leave office saying the entire thing was
was a fraud and a sham and all
it's not going to matter one iota if the
electoral college votes the way the
electoral college is probably going to
vote
given the current vote counts and the
certifications of state votes as they
currently stand
then we will all move on because that is
how the country works and people will be
pissed
and people will have doubts about the
voter process and people will call for
rectification of many of the areas of
voter
unfairness that we have seen across the
country and that's not necessarily a bad
thing
but chuck schumer of all people saying
that republicans are poisoning the well
of democracy says chuck
schumer come on instead of working to
pull the country back together
so that we can fight our common enemy
covet 19
republicans in congress are spreading
conspiracy theories
denying reality and poisoning the well
of our democracy
the republicans should stop their
shenanigans about an election that
president trump has
already lost and focus their attention
on the immediate issue at hand
providing relief to a country living
through the covet health
and economic crises okay by the way i do
love chuck schumer suggesting
that donald trump is so distracted that
he won't pass any sort of relief bill
you know who held up the relief bill we
all know who held up the relief bill
nancy pelosi in the house and it
probably cost her house colleagues
double digits
in the house yeah but chuck schumer
again this is all just nonsense it's all
nonsense and it is
it is self-flattering politically driven
nonsense my i think my favorite comment
of the last 24 hours
over all of this coup talk came from
seth meyers seth myers was like donald
trump that guy's a threat to democracy
also
let's get rid of the electoral college
he's a threat to the system let's
destroy the system let's get r
you know you know what i don't like i
don't like federalism anymore and i
don't like the electoral college anymore
let's get rid of all of those things
in order to restore democracy let's get
rid of all the institutions also donald
trump is a big threat to your
institutions here's idiot seth myers
it's not a good situation when you have
one political party
committed to democracy no matter the
outcome and the other opposed to
democracy at all costs
even if this ridiculous coup attempt
fails it doesn't bode well for the
future which is why we need
bold systemic reforms to empower
everyone to vote
and honor what the majority of voters
actually want like abolishing the
electoral college and fixing the voting
rights act
among other things these should be
no-brainers if we had a healthy
functioning political system both
parties would react to these ideas by
saying
sure it's done okay he's such a
i'm sorry
seth myers is a
okay when seth meyers says there that
one party is committed to democracy and
the other party is not committed to
democracy therefore the party committed
to democracy
should reinstate the voting rights act
which was put in place in the 1960s it
required
pre-clearance from the federal
government with regard with regard to
drawing of districts and was designed to
be phased out over time when it became
clear that these districts were not
drawn for
racial reasons and the supreme court
recently ruled the voting rights act was
no longer relevant
50 years after it been written he wants
that restored so the federal government
gets to rule the states on how the how
the districts are drawn
and then he also wants to get rid of the
electoral college but don't worry he's
the guy committed to democracy
he's totally committed to democracy
weird how the word democracy tends to
shift and change depending on exactly
what democrats
want from it but let's be real about
this all this really comes down to is as
usual orange man bads on lemon letting
the cat out of the bag
and being triumphant joe biden's super
popular and donald trump is super
unpopular
and this wasn't a close election here is
don lemon objective journalist getting
his journalism everywhere
joe biden has widened his lead over
trump in the popular vote by more than 5
million ballots in the popular vote
he's way more popular than trump
has ever been or will ever be
biden has tallied up more than 77
million votes
that's more than any presidential
candidate in american history
can you imagine how the man who is
obsessed with ratings and numbers
how that feels that's all it's about for
for the democrats and for the media but
i repeat myself
it's all about the schadenfreude of
suggesting that donald trump is getting
what he deserves because he's on poverty
by the way by this measure
you know who's more popular than than
any democrat who's who's ever lived
basically
is joe biden he's won more raw votes
right he's more popular than barack
obama by leaps and bounds now do you
actually think that don lemon believes
that
uh of course not of course not okay in
just one second we're going to get to
the the continuing self-flattering
narrative democrats are painting so
according to democrats
democrats love democracy also democrats
are the only people who care about covet
we'll get to that ridiculous narrative
in just one second as coveted spreads
across the country
first let us talk about the fact that a
lot of people have a balance on their
credit cards
and they're just leaving it there this
is like the worst thing you can do
financially it is the worst
thing because those credit card interest
rates they really start to rack up and
soon you are paying an absolute fortune
on the interest rates this is how people
get tens of thousands of dollars
into debt without really even noticing
it instead why not go refinance your
high interest credit card balances
and save with a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream
rates start at 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it'll never go up
over the life of the loan plus there are
no fees get a loan from 5 000 bucks to
100 000 bucks you can even get your
money as soon as the day
you apply lightstream believes that
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience that's exactly what they
are delivering
people love livestream here's what this
customer had to say said i heard about
lightstream on a podcast this podcast
was able to look on the website and get
clear information
the application process was quick and
easy i know people who have really
kind of lost their financial future
thanks to credit card debt get out of
credit card debt right now by
consolidating
those loans my listeners can save even
more with an additional interest rate
discount the only way to get the
discount go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's l i g h t s t r e a m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from five point nine five percent
apr to 19.99
apr and includes 0.50 auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply
and offers our subject to change that
notice visit lightstream.com for more
information okay so as part of the
democrats self-flattering narrative here
there are a couple things one they love
democracy republicans hate democracy
also
republicans love covid right this is
this is their other narrative is that
republicans love covet so here is the
reality
as some of us have been saying for quite
a while it turns out that nobody has a
good solution to covet
there are no good solutions to covet
this is why i have been suggesting
the only thing that you can really do is
expend resources trying to protect the
most vulnerable
among your population there's a study
recently published i believe in the wall
street journal
that suggested that the number of people
above the
who are on medicare in the united states
essentially everybody over the age
of 65 who have died of covid with no
pre-existing
conditions right above the age of 65 is
2 500. that means that what you actually
have to do
is protect not even the old but truly
you have to protect people with
pre-existing conditions okay now the
thing is in the united states
that's a lot of people because there are
a lot of people who have diabetes a lot
of people have asthma a lot of people
who have heart conditions
and hypertension could theoretically be
a contributing factor
to a bad reaction to covin but given
widespread community spread
not just here in the united states but
all over europe the fact is that
the only thing that you can do is shield
the most vulnerable and what that does
mean is that if you have vulnerable
people in your family you should wear a
mask around them and socially distance
right that's just the smart thing to do
i have two grandmothers
both of whom are over the age of 90.
thank god they're still alive and
doing decently and if i visited them i
would definitely not visit them without
a face mask
or without being several feedback right
i mean at least six feet back
and that is the smart thing to do and
that's the only thing you can do
now there's this weird idea out there
that if you just lock everything down
this is going to solve everything but of
course locking everything down is not
going to solve everything all you're
going to end up doing is prolonging the
agony in the sense that
you lock it down and then eventually you
have to reopen so
yes a vaccine is on the way but the
vaccine is not going to be widely
available we are told until march or
april
is anybody realistically suggesting that
we all be confined to our homes
from november until march is anybody
really suggesting that at this point
even the who doesn't suggest that that
is a good idea even anthony fauci
suggests that that is not a good idea
anthony fauci is about as hawkish on
lockdowns
as anybody in the american federal
government right now fauci appeared on
good morning america yesterday
and he said there's no appetite for
locking down we shouldn't be pushing
full scale lockdowns at this point
there is no appetite for locking down uh
on the american public but i believe
that we can do it
without a lockdown i really do i mean
sometimes when people talk about
the measures that i'm suggesting we
double down on
they equivocate that and say that well
that that
makes that not a lockdown it isn't
necessarily lockdown you could still get
businesses going
you could still have economic uh forward
thinking
while you're doing that you don't
necessarily have to shut everything down
okay so that actually is accurate right
okay and republicans basically across
the country are saying the same thing
they're saying
okay because they're saying mostly what
i'm saying right be cautious don't go
out into crowded areas if you are going
to be in crowded areas then make sure
that you wear a mask and you try to
socially distance as much as possible
like we're all on the same page here
it is not as though there's this vast
split in terms of where the american
mind is
doesn't matter democrats have declared
that if you are a republican you really
you literally want people to die so
nancy pelosi yesterday she said
that republicans and the gop should be
carrying deaths on their conscience
this is the lady who's eaten ice cream
in front of her sub-zero fridge
while declaring that she was not going
to be passing a covered relief bill she
was holding up a coveted relief bill at
the time
she's still holding up a coveted relief
bill by the way if you are in favor of
more lockdowns you know what you need to
pass a coveted relief bill because there
are a bunch of people who aren't going
to be able to go to work how do you
think they're going to be able to pay
your bills
i mean it's wild nancy pelosi
the woman who was saying come on down to
chinatown and party with us in late
february
is now declaring that it's republican's
fault that this thing has spread
across the country even as she held up
the relief bill
for her own nefarious political purposes
which completely backfired on her own
caucus
this is the master politician here she
was yesterday declaring again herself on
the side of the angels and her enemies
on the side of satan
if the republicans want to be
cold-hearted
and say they don't care or as the
president's son said
100 225 000 i think at that time
that's no big number kind of thing no
every single one of those deaths
is important to us we carry those people
in our hearts
and they should be carrying them on
their conscience for what they did not
do
since we passed the bill the heroes act
over a hundred thousand more people have
died
that could have been prevented okay she
has never explained exactly how she
would have prevented
those people from dying nor will she
look will she explain
fauci is still in the trump
administration probably trump's
formulations about fouchy
dude is still in the in the federal
government alex azar the secretary of
health and human services
under trump said yesterday that during
thanksgiving we have to make sacrifices
to keep people alive that might mean
fewer parties more social distancing
more mass squaring like there is no vast
gap here between republicans and
democrats
the only vast gap is that democrats have
taken the political incentive structure
and completely perverted it so they are
now in favor of
vast lockdowns including of places that
are not risk centers like schools
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about
a service that is just fantastic okay
this is one i'm enjoying personally like
on a really personal level i'm talking
about myphoto.com
it's awesome okay so on your phone you
have a bunch of photos not done anything
with them because it is a giant pain in
the butt to try and make some sort of
photo book out of all of those photos
or to print it out and go to a framing
store or something instead what you need
is myphoto.com
it is crazy easy and it's crazy fast
takes any photo and makes it into a
metal
glass wood picture i mean these
beautiful pieces
it literally takes two minutes to do it
i get it in five days it comes in a
stunning gift box makes a great holiday
gift
with the holidays coming up i barely
need to do anything to make something
personal and special so i took a couple
of pictures i sent them
directly into myphoto.com literally took
two minutes and just five days later i
got in the mail this beautiful
acrylic frame it really shines it's
beautiful of me and my kids
at a wedding recently it's really
terrific you got to try it right now go
to myphoto.com you can easily see your
photo on all their products and then you
simply purchase
you can use the promo code ben25 today
for 25
off again use promo code ben25 today for
25 off you're gonna get beautiful
products
great holiday gifts go to myphoto.com
right now
use the code ben25 and get 25 off
especially this holiday season when you
might not be able to see
friends and family face to face makes a
fantastic holiday gift you'll see how
easy and fun it is and you can do it
like
every month you can do it every couple
weeks right you see you have a great
photo
mail it in boom it comes back and now
you put it right on your desk it's just
great
and by the way i know the founders of
the company excellent honorable people
go check it out right now myphoto.com
use the code ben25 and get
25 off okay so as i say
there is no partisan conflict over the
fact that when it comes to covet people
should exercise
a certain level of caution this is not
particularly controversial here is
secretary of health and human services
alex azar who
is a member of the trump administration
saying that we need to be cautious about
this
reduce the number of people at your
gathering if you can open the windows
let more ventilation and we've got very
practical things even if you have a
ceiling fan
set it so it pulls the air up instead of
down use single use
servings for individuals wear your face
coverings because
i want to make sure even if we make
sacrifices this thanksgiving and
christmas the sack of those sacrifices
are for a reason
so that everybody you want to be with
will be here for next thanksgiving
and next question next christmas okay so
again not a huge gap except
the democrats have artificially created
a gap about covet where if you just say
you know what
the economy should remain open you
should be careful you should try to
shield
your fellows who are particularly
vulnerable then this means you're evil
right you're on the side of satan
even as nancy pelosi holds up the
coveted relief efforts you're on the
side of satan
and so democrats have decided that
because of the incentive structure it's
time for full
lockdowns full lockdowns are back on the
table
except by the way if you are celebrating
some sort of woke cause if you're
celebrating a world class in lockdowns
don't matter anymore
as we all know covet is the wokest virus
that ever was it does not affect anybody
who attends a black lives matter rally
but it'll hit everybody
at a trump white house event it has
never affected a non-trump voter
it turns out that this virus is uh it's
sort of a holy virus in the view of the
left it only hurts people
who do the wrong things it's like it's
like santa claus it keeps a list
it checks it twice and then it comes
after you if you were naughty and not
nice
anyway here was biden's spokeswoman
yesterday ducking whether he would
actually attempt a national lockdown
which is like
good luck first of all you don't have
the power under the constitution of the
united states thank god
to impose a national level lockdown
particularly in january we don't even
know where this thing is going to be in
january
but i think that you should pretty much
commit that you are not going to use an
executive order to try and lock down
the entire american economy i mean if
you want to talk about the essence of
tyranny that would be it
the president of the united states
declaring you know what national
lockdown time
here is biden spokeswoman literally
refusing to answer the question
is that something that president-elect
biden is considering a four to six week
lockdown
well i think he laid out very clearly
across the course the campaign the
things that he wants to do to get the
virus under control including
encouraging national mass mandates but
what does that mean no plans for
uh a lockdown but that could change uh
i mean he's on the michael osterholm's
on the task force
there are steps that we can take now
again encouraging people to wear masks
again they're just gonna say mass mass
mask but they'll hold and abandons the
possibility
of a total lockdown of the american
economy and mayors all over the country
who are democrats are now calling for a
total lockdown
except when they're not so chicago mayor
lori lightfoot issued another lockdown
advisory she demanded that you cancel
your thanksgiving plans starting on
monday according to the chicago tribune
she'll impose a 10-person ceiling on
gatherings such as weddings
funerals and other events she also
tweeted out a stay-at-home advisory for
chicago will go into effect on monday
november 16th
at 6 00 a.m by the way i do love these
delays as though what did the virus like
not
like is delayed for the next three days
or so like if you can issue this
advisory
shouldn't you do it like right now is
that big an emergency this advisory
calls on all chicagolands to do the
following stay home
unless for essential reasons stop having
guests over including family members you
do not live with
avoid non-essential travel and cancel
your thanksgiving plans
by the way i will just note that um the
the
queen of science who yesterday released
an entire video about how much she
values science
uh this was her like six days ago at a
rally
in the open with no mask on shouting
into a loudspeaker about joe biden
that's a picture of her right there is
this here she goes
this is a great day for our country we
get to take our democracy back
giant crowd in the streets many not
wearing nests for all those people
who voted you made this happen
okay so that was okay that was okay six
days ago that was okay
now you can't have grandma and grandpa
over for thanksgiving dinner even if
you're being cautious and socially
distancing
so yeah i definitely trust these people
and don't think this is political at all
how about bill de blasio no de blasio's
doing the same thing so bill de blasio
was asked about andrew cuomo's
restrictions
on cnn last night he said i think that
andrew cuomo's new restrictions that
basically say that we're going to shut
down bars and restaurants after 10 p.m
because covet apparently does not apply
before 10 pm
also saying that you can't have 10
people in your backyard
but you can't have eight people in your
house which makes no sense at all
here's bill de blasio saying these
standards make perfect sense to him
he and i have talked about this a lot i
think he's in the right place i think it
will help for sure and
and the additional work that's being
done in staten island particular i think
is going to help
a lot uh look the goal here
is to turn this around we're still at
one of the lowest levels of positivity
in the country
we can drive it down again okay um and
i'm just gonna note that like again six
days ago here was bill de blasio in the
streets celebrating with people
it's liberation it's just joyous people
have felt this weight
and a sense of we're divided and we we
shouldn't be that way and now there's a
feeling that anything's possible that we
can heal again that we can move forward
and look joe biden and kamala harris did
something amazing
this is turning out to be a huge victory
okay so many countries
somebody somebody should have told bill
de blasio that there were a bunch of
orthodox jews having like a prayer
session behind him maybe we'd have done
something up the giant ass crowd
directly behind him
celebrating in the middle of a pandemic
that was apparently totally fine by the
way the rewritten history by which
donald trump is responsible for
everything coveted related
let me just take you back to like
mid-february ronald klein is the
incoming chief of staff for joe biden if
joe biden
is in fact legally made the president's
elect of the united states
here's a ronald claim tweet from the
middle of february
he was responding to a tweet from bill
de blasio february 13th it was my honor
to spend time
with our asian american-owned small
businesses in flushing today this
vibrant community is standing strong but
they need your support our china towns
are open for business
make some dinner plans do some shopping
stand with our neighbors
this is from all the captains of science
who are saying that they would have
changed everything had they been in
charge in february okay ronald klein
okay that is the new incoming jobiden
chief of staff here is what he tweeted
he tweeted
we don't have a coveted 19 epidemic in
the united states but we are starting to
see a fear epidemic
kudos to mayor bill de blasio and others
for standing against that
so it's not that everybody does their
best here and people make mistakes
is that the political priors decide
everything they they do
if donald trump was was talking about
the dangers of the wuhan virus in
february then it was xenophobic and you
should go down to chinatown
if donald trump started talking about
how the issues with covered were
overblown then it was lock everything
down immediately
the binary nature of politics is one of
the stupidest things in the world
one of the dumbest things ever anyway
again
cnn was spending the week talking about
how these parties in the streets
is this celebration this block party
that was happening all over the united
states it was good and then yesterday
they had on a medical guest and they
were like you know what you should
cancel thanksgiving
because gathering should not be the norm
less is more this thanksgiving it is the
covert thanksgiving
we don't want to give the virus while
we're giving thanks we want to protect
grandma and grandpa and we do that by
keeping ourselves as
separate as possible as much as we would
like to get together
this year separation should be the norm
please everybody be careful we don't
want thanksgiving to be a spreader event
okay
honestly i don't disagree with a lot of
this because
bottom line is that people are going to
have to act in responsible fashion i'm
just not going to hear it from a bunch
of people
who five seconds ago were saying it's
totally fine to gather in the streets
and swing from the
same champagne bottle because you don't
like donald trump it's just it's so
irritating and so stupid and it
undermines faith
in science it undermines faith in the
media the same people who shout science
are at the same time shouting that
racism is a scientific
issue that requires you to be out in the
streets like i'm sorry i'm not going to
pay any attention to you guys i'm just
not
right i'll pay attention to people who
have been consistent that large-scale
gatherings in the middle of a pandemic
are bad all the way through like those
people i will listen to
i will listen to people who have said
that we should be cautious all along i'm
not gonna listen to people
who are like either willy-nilly
depending on your political point of
view you can do what you want or you
can't do what you want it at all
like that that undermines public trust
we'll get to more of this in just one
second and
we'll get to the battle that is now
raging inside the democratic party
between the democrats
and the radicals between the so-called
mainstream and the radicals and the
radicals are going to win
the reason the radicals are going to win
is because they are the mainstream okay
the fact is
that the moderates inside the democratic
party are now the minority in their own
party and the reason is because of
barack obama
and he's making this very clear with his
voluminous tome
of memoirs we'll get to that in one
second first
you know you have one asset that is
probably worth more than all of your
other assets
maybe combined that of course is your
home and you really don't have to worry
about somebody stealing your home right
i mean it's not like somebody backs up a
brinks truck and then they just load
your home onto the back but what they
can do however is they can steal
the asset value you have in your home
title a cyber thief can find your home
title
digitize kept in government and business
servers or in the cloud forge your
signature on a quick claim deed
stating you sold your home to that
hacker and then done
he takes out loans against your home
until all your equity is gone and you
have just
piles of debt you won't know until the
collection calls start pouring
in you're not protected by insurance
your bank or common identity theft
programs home title lock can protect you
home title lock puts a barrier around
your home's title the instant they
detect tampering they help shut it down
cold
go to home title lock.com right now
register your address and you can
already see
if you're a victim then use code radio
for 30 free days
of protection you know it's one of those
things that you're going to feel a lot
more secure about because you know that
your most valuable asset is now
protected
and you probably have a safe in your
house to protect your valuables even
though you're not super worried about
somebody breaking in
well if they steal the stuff in your
safe probably is worth some money it
ain't worth the same as your house go
protect
your home asset value today use code
radio at home title lock.com for 30
free days of protection okay so
meanwhile
the democrats are trying to cope with
the fact that they lost a bunch of seats
in the house
that they are in all likelihood not
going to gain the senate
and this battle has broken out into the
open between the
between the democratic radicals and the
so-called moderates inside the
democratic party biden is supposed to be
a representative
of the moderate democratic party a
return to normalcy there's only one
problem
the heart and soul of the democratic
party is not controlled by the moderates
party is controlled by the radicals
because barack obama was a radical
posing as a moderate
he took over the party and he shaped
that party in his image
joe biden in order to be returned to
normalcy would have to be a return to
the pre-obama era but he is not he's not
a return to the pre-obama era the only
reason that he
is apparently the president-elect at
this moment according to media
projections
is because he is supposedly following in
the footsteps
of barack obama who was one of the great
political prevaricators
of modern american history i mean truly
and the the battle between the moderates
and the non-moderates in the democratic
party
has broken out really really radically
according to politico
it was the biggest surprise on election
night democrats instead of growing their
house majority actually lost seats
now the party is going through an
internal reckoning on what went wrong
the clearest picture of what happened
will come when a full breakdown of how
donald trump and joe biden fared
in individual districts across the
country is available but the most
shocking results available thus far make
it clear
trump did far better in than polling
indicated he would in many suburban
battlegrounds and in others
republican congressional candidates may
have benefited from ticket splitters
overall it looks like 2018 was a high
water mark for democrats a wave that
crested and fell
democrats unexpected losses ranged from
districts in florida and texas where
sliding latino support provided costly
blue training suburbs where affluent
voters split their tickets and rural
seats in which trump's gop
roared back last week in the end
democrats could end up losing around 10
seats depending on the final accounts
it'll probably more now probably be like
13 or 14.
here are the most surprising
congressional race of 2020 and then they
name a bunch of areas in which incumbent
democrats
lost their district and lost pretty
heavily yeah the point of this
and pretty much everybody in the
democratic party knows it is that
the moderate democrats got blown out
because they were tied
to the radical democrats one person who
knows this is senator joe manchin right
joe manchin
has always sort of been on the bubble he
keeps getting elected in west virginia
which is an extremely red state at this
point
west virginia in terms of presidential
elections it votes like
65 35 in favor of the republican
candidate but joe manchin
because he's sort of an older style
moderate democrat who very often votes
with republicans he's been able to
survive so he tweeted this out he
tweeted out
defund the police defund my butt i'm a
proud west virginia democrat we are the
party of working men and women we want
to protect americans jobs
and health care we do not we do not have
some crazy socialist agenda and we do
not believe
in defunding the police all of which
prompted the honorable representative
alexander ocasio-cortez d
crazy towns to tweet out a picture of
herself glaring
at joe manchin because during the state
of the union address joe manchin had its
i believe applaud for some tax cuts and
aoc
sat behind him and glared at him okay
this is
the slay queen please continue
continuing
i want her to primary uh chuck schumer i
i really really do
okay glaring at your mansion by the way
chances that joe manchin
switches to the republican party over
the course of the next couple of years
i would say at least 50 50 because
otherwise he's gonna lose his seat
because if he gets tied to that wing of
his party he's toast in west virginia
but here is the thing for all the
democrats declaring that they are not in
fact the party of alexandra
ocasio-cortez and the squad makes it
very difficult to claim that when nancy
pelosi
is literally posing on covers with
alexander ocasio-cortez and the squad
right she's not appearing on magazine
covers with abigail spanberger and conor
lamb
she's appearing with the hottest new
things in the new media with all the
twitter instagram crowd
right the people who make for good
clap-back tweets
but have no actual ability to get
anything done other than shouting
socialism at the moon
it's a real problem for the democrats as
kevin mccarthy the house minority leader
said
what this election shows more than
anything is that there's a mandate
against socialism and republicans are
right about this
not one republican incumbent lost
republicans won from miami to new york
to minnesota to california
the only seat the democrats won was an
open seat
and then they claimed to have won a
redistricting in north carolina
where republicans didn't even run i
heard the speaker called a mandate
it was a mandate against socialism
it was a mandate against defunding the
police
it was a mandate against wasting a
majority
that the democrats have done for the
last congress okay so
the democrats have been pushing back
against this by saying we're not
socialists and we're not defunding the
police
we're not that radical there is only one
problem this is not the party of bill
clinton if bill clinton ran on his 1992
platform today
he'd be in the republican party real
talk okay that is that is the reality
this is barack obama's democratic party
and barack obama's democratic party is
not in fact the party of hillary clinton
or joe biden even barack obama's
democratic party is
the party of alexander ocasio-cortez it
is the party for to leave it is the
party of wilhelm omar he was just better
at hiding it
what barack obama was great at doing was
pretending that he was in the mold of
old school democrats when actually
he's just an intersectional politician
who is deeply
ensconced in all of the lies of the
socialist
and and race-baiting left and barack
obama was
excellent at lying about this this is
what and we'll get to his memoir in just
a second because it really does spell
all of this out
if you read what we now know about his
memoir if you read it
what you will see is that barack obama
in ideology is much closer to people
like ibram x kendi or robin d'angelo
than he is
to joe manchin we'll get to that in just
one moment first
shopping for a home and auto insurance
it can seem like a daunting task but
protecting the things you've worked for
hard is very important the trick is
knowing where to find the right coverage
at the best possible price
that is why policy genius makes it easy
they combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time
and save you money policy genius saves
their home and auto customers an average
of a thousand bucks per year by
reshopping their rates
here's how it works first you head on
over to policygenius.com you'll answer a
few quick questions about yourself
and your property then policy genius
does the rest they compare rates from
over 30 top insurers from progressive to
nationwide
to find the lowest quotes their licensed
experts will look at all the ways to
maximize your savings including bundling
your home and auto policies
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you are currently paying they
will get you switched over for free
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you're a
homeowner head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started they save their home and auto
insurance customers an average of one
thousand dollars a year
by reshopping policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice it's very
important to get it right and again they
can do all sorts of insurance for you
not just home and auto they'll do
disability they'll do life insurance
they'll take care of all your insurance
need go check them out
right now at policygenius.com all right
we're going to get into
barack obama and how this is barack
obama's party but it's not barack
obama's moderate party it's barack
obama's radical party his memoirs are
making that absolutely clear
we'll get to that in one second first if
you're not already disgusted by the
legacy media you absolutely should be
the media preemptively called the
election in favor of joe biden like on
election night they are further claiming
that trump
is undermining america he's undermining
democracy by not conceding even though
there is no legal obligation for him to
concede
just because cnn and fox news say
something that doesn't actually make it
true
it means they are pushing particular
narratives our founder god king jeremy
boring details this travesty in the
latest episode of his new podcast
enough his first episode released a few
weeks ago it immediately charted number
six on all apple podcasts go check it
out leave review if you like what he has
to say
not only did the media declare the
election for biden the media has already
shifted from demonizing
trump and his supporters to flattering
biden and harris before they've even
taken office i mean they're providing
him
the full body massage well if you're
sick of the media feeding you the
narrative replace your cable replace
your new subscriptions
with the daily wires stop paying the
people who are feeding you
actual narrative misinformation and
here's the thing over at daily wire we
plan on replacing the media we have big
plans it starts today candace owens new
york times best-selling author and
founder of the blexit foundation is
joining the daily wire
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us early next year we're also
launching an entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team
we are building partnerships with
like-minded content creators like
prageru whose entire show library will
be available to dailywire.com members by
the end of the year
we are going after the legacy media
we're going to do it by building a huge
membership base of supporters like you
it's not just that you
get great content you're part of the
team in helping to take down one of the
institutions that is a key component
of democratic dominance right now just
to show you we're serious we are
offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe
members get our articles ad free access
to all of our live broadcast and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show and
exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily wire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for live stream
discussions with our hosts and an
amazing online community you also get
not one but
two leftist years tumblers with your
membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products so remember it's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
daily wire you won't regret it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so let's talk about the fact
that this is barack obama's democratic
party
so the battle inside the democratic
party right now between the so-called
moderates the joe manchins of the party
or even the joe bidens of the party
against the sort of alexander
ocasio-cortez squad
elizabeth warren bernie sanders wing of
the party that battle is over and the
reason that the battle
is over is because there is no immune
response to the argument that is being
made
by people like ocasio-cortez the the
people like rashida talib the people
like elizabeth warren which is that the
system itself is deeply corrupt
the reason there is no immune response
is because barack obama killed the
immune response
the great lie of barack obama's tenure
is that he was a unifying president who
believed in foundational american
principles he absolutely did not
the 2012 election i think broke the
country because in 2008 barack obama was
elected
along the lines of i am here to unify
i'm here red states no blue states
united states we've had a lot of racial
conflict in this country in my own
person
i have felt that pain but now i am a
symbol of hope
right that was his whole 2008 campaign
and then come 2012
everybody who opposed him was a racist
sexist bigot homophobe
if you didn't like him it was because
you had not uncovered the bigotry in
your own heart
and in fact his agenda was about a
vision for the country that may have
moved beyond the founders okay so now he
has a memoir out
and the memoir is making pretty damned
clear where it comes from okay the
memoir is not vague
it's it's it is slightly coded
when i say it's slightly coded i mean
that he pays sometimes lip service to
what he says are american principles
that are actually not foundational
american founding principles but barack
obama
is the he is the pathway for the
democratic party moving forward
right that's what they think this is
what the democratic party thinks and
this is why
the future of the democratic party looks
a lot more like the squad and a lot less
like joe manchin which is why you have
that
that particular tweet from aoc glaring
at your mansion right that is the future
of the democratic party it's radicals
all the way down
okay so barack obama releases a 768-page
volume one of his memoir first of all
for anybody who believes that donald
trump has narcissistic personality
disorder let me introduce you to a man
named barack obama
nobody has ever loved barack obama more
than barack obama loves barack obama
jeffrey tubin doesn't love jeffrey
toobin as much as barack obama loves
barack obama
okay it is it is absurd how much barack
obama loves himself in barack obama the
man
has written at this point this is his
third memoir and volume one
is longer as i have said than the five
books of moses not kidding
in the original hebrew this is a
768-page memoir
that's volume one hey he didn't
accomplish anything when he was
he did obamacare and then he had a bunch
of executive orders and he undermined
the fundamental unity of the country so
i guess there was
there are a few things that he did but
is that worthy of like 1500
pages maybe he'll just continue writing
these memoirs forever
i don't know winston churchill wrote
this many memoirs and winston churchill
is actually an important human
i don't think that barack obama is a
particularly important human in the vast
panorama
of american politics except for
destructive things that he has done to
the body politic
okay but that doesn't stop the media
from just drooling over in the new york
times book review
barack obama is as fine writer as they
come it is not merely this book of voids
being ponderous as might be expected
even forgiven of a hefty memoir but that
it is nearly always pleasurable to read
sentence by sentence that prose gorgeous
in places
the detail granular and vivid jeffrey
tube in writing that
right there i mean that that is a lot of
lot of book review journalism
going on right there okay so what does
barack obama actually say
in his memoirs well we have an early
expert from the atlantic another place
that is basically a barack obama
stenographer jeffrey goldberg famously
was sort of the place that barack obama
would go to vomit all of his bile at his
enemies and jeffrey goldberg would just
sit there and write it and not along
in fact jeffrey goldberg was so much of
a tool of the obama administration that
ben rhodes
who's a fiction writer who helped craft
the iran deal the garbage iran deal
openly stated that he used jeffrey
goldberg's as a stenographer for his
idiotic
residionic politics anyway the atlantic
which
fired kevin williamson for the sin of
being pro-life but obviously will print
nearly anything abram kennedy
writes over there they they printed some
of barack obama's memoir
here is the here is are the paragraphs
that that stick out the most
okay so the theme of barack obama's
presidency and his life
is that he is disappointed in you you
get this from michelle obama to he's
disappointed in you
and he's disappointed in american
democracy because what he wants from you
and from american democracy
is a radical remaking he wants a radical
re-shifting
he talks about the contest between
democrats and republicans
and of course it goes to this deeper
point that democrats have fallen head
first into
which is that if you do not believe and
the democrats radical agenda on every
score
is because you're a racist sexist bigot
homophobe this is barack obama
a twice elected president by wide
margins both times talking about how the
american people are garbage
he says this contest is not new
right right now we are seeing a crisis
rooted in a fundamental contest between
two opposing visions of what america is
and what it should be a crisis that has
left the body politic divided angry and
mistrustful and has allowed for an
ongoing breach of institutional norms
procedural safeguards and the adherence
to basic facts both republicans and
democrats once took for granted first of
all being lectured on basic facts by
captain if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor is somewhat going
but barack obama says this contest is
not new of course in many ways
it has defined the american experience
it's embedded in founding documents that
could simultaneously proclaim all men
equal and yet counts a slave as
three-fifths of a man
it finds expression in our earliest
court opinions as when the chief justice
of the united states bluntly explains to
native americans that their tribe's
rights to convey property aren't
enforceable because the court of the
conqueror has no capacity to recognize
the just claims of the conquered
it's a contest that's been fought on the
fields of gettysburg and appomattox but
also in the halls of congress
on a bridge in selma alabama across the
vineyards of california and down the
streets of new york a contest fought by
soldiers
but more often by union organizers
suffragists pullman porters student
leaders waves of immigrants and lgbtq
activists
armed with nothing more than picket
signs pamphlets or a pair
of marching shoes at the heart of this
long-running battle is a simple question
do we care to match the reality of
america to its ideals
do we really believe that our notions of
self-government and individual freedom
equality of opportunity and equality
before the law apply to everybody or
are we instead committed in practice if
not in statute preserving those things
for a privileged few right again if you
don't believe in all the radical policy
prescriptions of barack obama
then you believe in reserving freedom
and prosperity and equality of
opportunity to a privileged few now
you're a bad person not only are you a
bad person it turns out
um you might be a racist and also the
founding fathers might be a racist so he
he says
i'm all in favor of founding principles
even though i might not really believe
that the founding principles are in fact
the founding principle
right here here's where we get into the
radical 1619 project territory of barack
obama's thought he says
i recognize there are those who believe
it's time to discard the myth that an
examination of america's past
and an even cursory glance at today's
headlines show that this nation's ideals
have always been secondary to conquest
and subjugation a racial caste system
and rapacious capitalism and that to
pretend otherwise is to be complicit in
a game that was rigged from the start
and i confess there have been times
during the course of writing my book as
i've reflected on my presidency and all
that's happened since
when i've had to ask myself whether i
was too tempered and speaking the truth
as i saw it too cautious and either word
or deed
convinced as i was that by appealing to
what lincoln called the better better
angels of our nature
i stood a greater chance of leading us
in the direction of the america we've
been promised i don't know
he doesn't know you know he doesn't know
he doesn't know if these were actually
maybe the myth maybe the myth is wrong
maybe america was founded in racist
sexism bigotry homophobia
exploitation and then he says what i can
say for certain is i'm not yet ready to
abandon the possibility
of america oh so so again you guys you
just keep disappointing barack obama but
here's the thing
in order to not disappoint barack obama
what you have to do is you just have to
concede
that's what you need to do you need to
concede to all of his radical opinions
and if you don't it's because you want a
worse america you're a bad person
okay this is aoc kind of language this
is not the language of unity this is not
the language of discussion
this is not the language of a common
vision for the future this is the
language of radicalism
barack obama speaks it fluently he's
able to cover it in a way that the
radicals and the squad aren't but he is
just he's every bit as radical as they
are
he just gets it just takes him a little
bit longer to word his way around it
this is what made him good at what he
did it's also what makes him an emma gog
okay so let's talk for a second about
barack obama's role in polarizing the
country
so i know that there is this myth this
media created myth that barack obama
brought the country together
he was just he was great his only
scandal is a town suit wonderful
wonderful man captain unity
over here and that barack obama's
unifying figure in american public life
he is absolutely not barack obama was a
radical in sheep's clothing
he always was he threw dreams from my
father he makes this very clear he says
in dreams for my father
that the same things drive terrorism in
jakarta as drive
crime in the heart of chicago right not
ideology not philosophy
but poverty right there's a marxist
vision of how the world works that
poverty drives crime
and terrorism and if you just correct
the economic problems then everything is
fine
he also has a very essentialist vision
of race in the united states his belief
of race in the united states is that we
ought not treat people as individuals
but that we ought to treat people as
members of groups as intersectional
groups
right you're victim if you are a member
of a particular group
and in fact because barack obama is a
member of a group right because barack
obama is black barack obama is a victim
too and he makes this clear in his
memoir
he's a victim a man who's elected by an
overwhelmingly overwhelming majority of
the voting public of the united states
in both 2008 and 2012
is apparently a victim of deep-seated
american racism and any inability to
effectuate his agenda is because number
one the american people are too stupid
and number two because the american
people
are too racist this is the great this is
the great shift that has happened in our
politics
okay if you look back to 2000 or even to
2004 they're pretty significant
differences between the party
particularly in terms of economic vision
but there was no great argument about
the foundations of the country
there was no great argument that america
was essentially and in its root racist
and you heard people calling each other
racist for no apparent reason and
because they thought that it was
politically
popular to do so but the truth is that
that argument was largely
ignored it was largely seen as
overwrought
see if you go back to the 1960s when a
lot of these issues first sprang
full-blown
into the american public consciousness
now obviously they've been simmering
under the surface and some for quite
good reason have been simmering under
the surface
and that bubble bursting in the 60s had
some very good effects and it had some
very bad effects
obviously the good effects would be the
civil rights movement the bad effects
would be the complete destruction
of traditional notions of morality for
example okay but
in the 1960s a couple of things happened
one
there was a failure of the liberal
vision when it came to the role of
government in american life
so in the 1960s there was a vision
there's a vision of the anointed
that suggested the government could cure
all problems and so government on an
economic level
was going to take on new burdens it was
going to cure all the problems it was
going to overthrow the rapacious rule of
capitalism and it was going to guarantee
the fundamental freedoms promised by fdr
freedom from fear freedom from want and
all the rest of this right this is lbj's
great society program
government was now going to care for all
of us so that was movement number one
there was simultaneously a second
movement and that was a movement to
fight racism in american life
initially an excellent excellent
movement because it was in fact fighting
racism in american life it culminated in
the civil rights act
right and all that was good and then in
the late 60s the notion of racism itself
began to transmute shelby steele talks
about this
the definition of racism began to move
from people
thinking of each other as inferior based
on race or crafting policy in order to
make another
race worse off and it shifted into
something significantly more vague
something that didn't make a hell of a
lot of sense right that was
any inequality of outcome could be
attributable to the system
the system was responsible for all
inequality and therefore the system
itself was inequitable and the system
had to be torn down this was a
perspective first mouthed in the late
1960s by stokely carmichael
who at the time uh was the head of uh of
it was before he was that of the black
panthers actually so stokely carmichael
suggested
institutional racism right the idea was
that any institution
that ended with inequality between
groups was a racist institution
this could include things like freedom
of speech if freedom of speech ended
with more inequality between black and
white and freedom freedom of speech
itself was a tool of the powerful
against the oppressed right this is what
barack obama's talking about in that
little section of his memoir quoted
earlier in the atlantic where he says
there are people who believe that all
the systems of the united states are
basically a myth
a cover for oppression and power
dynamics
barack obama kind of believes that too
so that was a stokley carmichael point
talking about the institutions of the
united states you had these two
simultaneous movements right
one was that government had the power to
correct all the economic ills of the
entire society and fix everything
and the second was that all of the
institutions
of government were themselves infused
and infected
with racism and bigotry and power
dynamics and exploitation
well it turns out over the course of the
subsequent 20 or 30 years both of these
narratives
started to fall apart so first of all
the narrative that government was
capable of taking care of you through
all circumstances and fixing all
problems and solving inequality
it completely fell apart by the 1970s
when the american economy started to
collapse in on itself
like a dying star right it ended with
the election of ronald reagan in 1980
after a decade of essentially economic
complete economic
stagnation between like the late 1960s
and 1980 pretty much
complete economic stagnation it ends
with the reagan revolution and that
culminates in
in bill clinton democrat claiming that
the era of big government is essentially
over
right so that was line number one from
the left that falls apart then there's
line number two from the left that falls
apart
and that is that there is no way to
overcome our racism in the united states
that what we have to do is we have to
shift our thinking on racism so as to
achieve
equality of outcome and this results
an actual widening of gaps in the united
states it results
in a in a slower growth of the black
middle class it results in
serious crime problems because as the
government starts to incentivize people
to commit crimes
not punish crimes you get this vast wave
of crime particularly in heavily
minority areas that are
disproportionately poor
and so by 1994 the republicans and the
democrats are getting together and they
are saying
okay this is not working we're going to
need to actually crack down on crime
what if we just treated everybody as an
individual what if we treated everybody
as an economic individual
in charge of their own life right the
era of big government is over and what
if we treated everybody as an individual
in terms of personal responsibility
if you commit a crime no matter what
your race you're going to go to jail
right and if you are cheating welfare
you're we're not going to give you
welfare welfare reform is now going to
be
a bipartisan thing in order to promote
work right we're going to treat you as
an individual we're not going to treat
you as a member of a group that has owed
some sort of
reparations by a perversion of the
system right so both of these twin
narratives from the 60s have basically
died by the early 1990s
and after the fall of the soviet union
they basically remained dead
right even throughout the bush
administration the growth of government
never really stops after after 9 11
right
the growth of government really picks up
and accelerates after 9 11.
but the basic idea in americans minds
that government can't solve all your
problems
and also that people ought to be treated
racially as individuals
right everybody should be treated as an
individual these basically become
centralizing principles and they exist
in both parties
in 2008 barack obama runs on both those
principles and barack obama
in 2008 barack obama says we need change
right because the middle of a recession
we need
we need change fundamental change but he
doesn't define the change
and so people say okay well he's sort of
moderate right joe biden himself says
he's the first guy that that white
people find non-threatening and what he
means by that is that he's not jesse
jackson
out there on the barricades shouting
about how america is endemically racist
right so barack obama comes along and he
campaigns as basically blah
right he campaigns as unity candidate
who in his very personage
is going to declare an end to the racial
conflict that has plagued the country
for so long the nation's founding sin he
is going to alleviate that founding sin
by allowing america to say
look look how far we've come look what
we've been able to accomplish he comes
in on the wings of eagles in 2008
blowing out john mccain an actual war
hero and he comes in
on the wings of having like five minutes
of legislative experience and making one
speech in 2004 at the dnc
that is his entire experience okay so he
comes in
and then what does he proceed to do he
proceeds to not only revivify
both of the 1960s narratives but to tie
them together
right in his person he proceeds to tie
them together two narratives again
government can solve all your problems
and two america its systems are itself
racist
and what he says is government can only
solve all of your problems
if the right people are running the
government and also if you refuse to
acknowledge the government can solve all
of your problems
it's because you want the systems to
remain racist and exploitative
and that's why barack obama can so
easily shift into this language where he
suggests
okay guys you know if you oppose my
agenda it's because you're racist it's
because you don't like me personally
it's not that you reject the fundamental
notion the government can solve all
these problems
it's because you hate me it's because
you're in favor of exploitation
it's because you're in favor of racism
so in his memoir barack obama makes this
absolutely clear
this was always his campaign right this
is what he did in 2012 he revivified
those two dead narratives
he tied them together he created a
coalition out of it
the coalition of the ascendant and then
he won in 2012 and democrats have been
trying to remake that coalition ever
since
and the problem is that joe biden
actually
campaigned in the same way that obama
did in 2008 but the coalition that he's
relying upon is barack obama's 2012
coalition with a few add-ons
and the base is not barack obama's wide
base of 2008
the base is still that core of 2012 from
barack obama
and so he's going to be very
hard-pressed to reject those people who
made him and who are
gonna continue to support his agenda
that's why the radicals are in charge so
barack obama's memoir makes all of this
perfectly clear apparently according to
cnn right which has an early copy of
this
this huge door stopper
obama writes it was as if my very
presence in the white house had
triggered a deep-seated panic a sense
that the natural order had been
disrupted
which is exactly why donald trump
understood when he started peddling
assertions that i had not been born in
the united states and was thus an
illegitimate president for millions of
americans spooked by a black man in the
white house he promised an elixir for
their racial anxiety
that's weird because donald trump
switched a bunch of states that barack
obama had won
right barack obama won wisconsin and
michigan and pennsylvania
he won florida donald trump switched all
of those
or he flipped all of those so were all
those people not racist when barack
obama was in office then racist later
how did that happen exactly but again
barack obama believes that anyone who
opposes his agenda
right the radical left agenda that says
government can solve all your problems
government is the only thing we have in
common
is what the dnc put up on its big board
at the at the 2012 dnc
if you don't believe that it's because
you hate barack obama
it's because you hate black people
according to barack obama
and he says this over and over and over
he says quote about sarah palin joining
the ticket in 2008 quote
through palin it seemed as if the dark
spirits that had long been lurking on
the edges of the modern republican party
xenophobia anti-intellectualism paranoid
conspiracy theories and antipathy for
black and brown folks were finding their
way to center stage
again barack obama identifying himself
as
america and if you oppose barack obama
you oppose america and
namely you really really don't like
black people is what barack obama
suggests and he keeps suggesting it over
and over and over the only there are
only two reasons according to barack
obama to ever oppose barack obama one is
you were stupid and the other one was
you were racist
it could also be both right so in 2010
after his party got shellacked
because it turns out americans rejected
obamacare they did not want obamacare
obama said as far as i was concerned the
election didn't prove our agenda had
been wrong
shocker it just proved that i'd failed
to rally the nation
which to me was just as damning oh it's
just about how the american people were
too stupid to understand what he was
saying
okay obama also says that that the
reason that he picked joe biden
to go and negotiate with the republicans
he literally says this
is because if he picked joe biden joe
biden was white
and the only and maybe he'd be able to
get his agenda through
maybe he'd be able to get his radical
agenda through if you put a white face
on it
because again the only reason to oppose
the agenda was not because you oppose
the agenda the only reason to oppose the
gender
is because you know like black people he
says quote one of the reasons i'd chosen
joe to act as an intermediary
in addition to his senate experience and
legislative acumen was my awareness that
in mcconnell's mind
negotiations with the vice president
didn't inflame the republican base in
quite the same way that any appearance
of cooperation with
black muslim socialist obama was bound
to do
okay so again the idea here is that joe
biden was only picked because he was
white
right because the american people are
are just
a bunch of vicious horrible racists
he talks about the henry lewis gates
incident
he says the reaction is my comments on
on gates this henry blue skates where he
said that the cambridge police acted
stupidly after arresting gates after
gates refused to show id
he says is my first indicator of how the
issue of black folks and the police was
more polarizing than just about any
other subject in american life
those feelings just continued during the
rise of palin and the tea party obama
writes recalling how michelle obama
caught a glimpse of a tea party rally on
tv
she sees the remote and turned off the
set her expression hovering somewhere
between rage
and resignation it's a trip isn't it she
said that they're scared of you
scared of us and that is what barack
obama did to the country
instead of us being able to hash out
economic issues instead of us arguing
about the
size and scope of government instead of
us acknowledging two basic truths
people should be treated as individuals
on the economic level and people should
be treated as individuals
without regard to race barack obama
reversed both of them and tied them
together
that is the democratic party the reason
this is important is not because of
barack obama it's because the democratic
party is now built
on that on that fused pillar
it is built on the graft between
socialistic ideology
and intersectional ideology they've been
tied together and that is the root of
the democratic party today
democrats are not going to be able to
escape this they cannot run away from it
it was born in barack obama it is not
going to die with barack obama
it is now in the bloodstream and it
ain't going away
that ideology that intersectional
socialistic ideology
that is not going away it has been
revivified and if you think that joe
biden is going to be able to ignore it i
have
serious doubts that he will be able to
ignore that okay so
at the end of every week i try to do a
little bit of bible talk because it's a
little bit inspirational going into the
weekend since we were talking about
socialism and property rights
there's been a weird idea in a lot of
philosophy a lot of western philosophy
going all the way back
and and not only western philosophy
philosophy globally
that private property is an evil if you
read rousseau the idea is that everybody
lived free and the first person who put
up a fence had somehow
sinned against original creation there
was this idea
of the of the noble savage living
in the wilderness and not believing in
private property now as it turns out on
an anthropological level that simply is
not true right people actually did
mark off territory they did claim
territory and that's always been true
but the idea
is that property itself is the root of
all evil now that is a
that is a misread of new testament
principles
in christian circles right the the
actual quote from the new testament
suggests
that greed is the root of all evil not
that property itself or property
ownership is the root of valuable love
of money not money
love of money is the root of all evil
right the quote from the new testament
about how it's it's easier for a camel
to pass through i have a needle than for
rich man sentence or heaven that it's
descriptive it is not normative it
doesn't mean that if you're rich
you can't stand for heaven it means it's
very difficult for a person who is rich
to enter heaven because they have the
lure of money at them at all times
okay but the one of the things about the
old testament the old testament is
pretty damn clear that private property
is not just something that is good it is
necessary
that there is a there is something
endemic to human nature that claims
property that property
is something we have to recognize as
something inherent it is not in fact a
social construct
it is not something that human beings
placed on each other as a method of
exploitation
property is a way for us to imprint our
stamp on the world
there's a great book by the historian
richard pipes on property that is well
worth getting he talks about this at
length
the sort of ideology and philosophy of
property
now on the right in american politics
there's a lot of talk about why private
property is useful
a sort of utilitarian take on capitalism
which is that
capitalism works right it makes
everybody richer it makes everybody more
prosperous
it allows for more freedom and thus it
is good okay but there's very little
sort of
moral explanation of why property
ownership is good property ownership is
good
because you are not just your body
you are the things around you right when
you think of your family you think of
them
as an extension of you and you think of
your house as an extension of you and
you think of your things as an extension
of you this goes all the way back to
childhood you can see little kids fight
over objects all the time
right it actually takes civilization in
order to get them to learn sharing
but little kids have an innate
animals have an innate capacity to claim
things right they want to claim the
things around them that is not
inherently bad
what is it in fact it can be very good
because it allows people to stake
a claim and then stand on that claim so
that comes up in this week's uh parsha
in this week's torah portion that the
jews read every week
this is the portion in which sarah dies
called hayasara it's from the book of
genesis
so after sarah dies abraham is trying to
find her a burial place
and he goes to covron he goes to hebron
and he buys the cave of machpelah
okay this is still now disputed
territory
uh it is it has always been jewish
territory according to
jewish philosophy abraham isaac and
jacob and adam are all buried
in i've actually been there it's it's an
amazing place
hebron it is in judea and samaria uh it
is it has
been made somewhat dangerous by the fact
that there are a lot of terrorists who
have tried to attack this particular
area
and muslims also do not allow jews to go
into particular areas of the mart
from for most of the year but the place
still exists
okay that is the first territorial claim
that the jewish people make
in the land of israel through a property
purchase and so what happens is that
abraham goes to
hebron he sees this cave he says i want
to buy that as a burial place
for my wife and the and the people who
own the place
they say you know what we're just going
to give it to you
and he says if it is your will that i
bury my dead but from before me listen
to me and entreat
for me to ephron the son of zohar that
he may give me machpelah that's a double
cave
which belongs to him it's at the end of
his field for a full price
let him give it to me in the midst for
burial property now efren was sitting in
the midst of the sons of het
and ephron the hittite answered abraham
in the hearing of the sons of head of
all those who'd come into the gate of
the city saying no my lord listen to me
i've given you the field and the cave
that is in it behold i've given it to
you
before the eyes of the sons of my people
i have given it to you bury your dead
and abraham spoke to efron in the
hearing of the people and he said but if
you only would listen to me i'm giving
the money for the field take it and i'll
bury my dead there and ephrain said
my lord listen to me a piece of land
with 400 shekels of silver what is it
between me and you bury your dead
and abraham listened to efron and
abraham weighed out to half around the
silver he had named in the hearing of
the sons of hit
400 shekels of silver accepted by the
merchant
right so the question is it seems like
everyone's trying to do a nice thing why
is abraham so insistent that he buy the
field
and the answer is because property
claims matter and as we as you can tell
certainly in the middle east
property claims matter property
ownership matters
and a consensual exchange of property
between people is an endemic good
because it clarifies the boundaries
between people
when we do not believe that property
matters you end up encroaching on those
boundaries
rather rather regularly those boundaries
become points of contention rather than
points of clarification
and there's the old robert frost phrase
that good fences make good neighbors
that happens to be true property
ownership makes for a polite society it
makes for a better society it makes for
a freer society because it is an
extension
of the reality that there are
individuals who have claims to things
that you do not have claims to
and that is something that is worth
remembering as we move forward into a
brave new era alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here on monday
try not to burn everything down we'll
see you then this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen